all right the dallas democratic party is
getting ridiculed online for a very good
reason they asked people to put together
care packages for texas lawmakers who
fled the state for d.c
rather than work with republicans on
voting reform some of the items the dems
think can only be found in texas include
dr
pepper salsa hard candy
hairspray toiletries and sanitizers
and sewing kits sewing kits but that's
not all
one texas state rep has been making an
outrageous claim about governor greg
abbott the governor
put out the call and he said that he was
going to round us up and corral us up
and bring us back
my son drives my car which has to take
place
and i just don't want uh some rural cop
or
some fanatic uh of the republican party
that listens to
uh governor abbott as they say they need
to bring us back because refugees
wow this is solely so poorly played over
the last two weeks
can anyone play this game dana what's
going on how does
texas how do these texas democrats plan
on winning over the american public
between the cobit 19
and now their desperate plea for basic
goods it's hard to imagine a publicity
stunt ever going worse than this one
this is the they are the tick tock texas
democrats
they got on a plane without a plan right
they're completely ineffective and then
they had to ask for hairspray
i mean that is something i mean kudos to
the
texas democrats who tweeted that uh they
needed hairspray
here's the thing these people are still
getting well you know what actually they
have a point about the salsa
not good except for one place la la
meter dose third in pennsylvania
southeast
amazing um but wait no i would tell you
this
realize that they're getting 221 dollars
per day from the taxpayers
so if you are somebody who's going to
put together a care package for these
people
think about the homeless in your area
the people who are going to a food bank
in your area do not send
one thing to these tick tock texas you
know who's running this
uh rich it looks like beter o'rourke is
running this he's their coach he keeps
zoom calling
says demand president biden get on a
zoom call with you
that's kind of scary your quarterback
stands on countertops
listen i can't speak to beta o'rourke or
the texas democrats but i will talk
about the issue that they're fighting
for because i think it's an important
issue that deserves
no part of candidates um look
i i think we do and listen the john the
john
the john lewis voting rights act which
is the voting rights act that we have
passed in this country from 1965 onwards
every president whether they were
democrats or republicans i'm pretty sure
dana worked on that bill when george
bush was president
right and it's something that every
party every party has signed this bill
why we can't get it done in this
congress is beyond me and
why mitch mcconnell is sending the way
of this bill which is something that is
the foundation of this country not for
the people actually i'm talking about
the john lewis voting rights act which
is different then the johnson that's
what's different than the the job it's
different
what's wrong with john lewis photography
no no you know what's different there's
something different about this bill
right no no there's nothing different go
take a look
no i i know we had the same conversation
last week
yeah and i'll continue to have this
conversation until we passed the john
lewis voting rights act because the idea
that states that have a history
of voter suppression have a history of
voting rights disenfranchisement and
what the john lewis voting rights act
says these states should have
pre-clearance in the justice department
whether it's a democratic justice
department
or republican justice department on how
their voting laws pass
this should be basic and fundamental why
do you think it's not being passed i'm
just curious
i don't know you should ask mitch
mcconnell because i don't know i don't
have his phone number but you
i would assume you would have the answer
because you keep bringing this up but
you don't know why
because we cannot get republicans to
vote on this why
they voted in every presidency before
you should ask that no no what's
different that's my point i'm just
anyway all right delivering the point uh
dagan it's 20
this is some of the things that they're
they're in um hibernation for
24-hour voting since when you go 24-hour
voting almost no state or county has
that
drive through voting since when you want
to be in a car afford supposed to be
private voting why do you want to have
pressure from the back seat to vote a
certain way for social districts yeah
and that was for social decency they do
two weekends a year 13 days early voting
uh they've expanded the actual hours of
voting they're demanded to give you a
day off for the voting
what's the problem here uh there is no
problem like
oh you don't like in middle of the night
voting drive through voting
there are regular voting booths right
that doesn't disenfranchise individuals
if you don't have 24-hour drive in
voting
period the bill also let me okay
i've got the floor uh these tesla's
democrats are doing
nobody any favor i i did some research
and tried to figure out the last time
that people after taking a private
jet flight halfway across the country
requested care packages
even though they were making money i'll
just end with this to give greg the
floor
in the words of livia soprano poor you
really which episode was that i don't
remember a lot of them okay
i have no i just have no sympathy at all
for these
if i were they didn't game plan this
year if i were a real jerk
i would find out it's probably very easy
to find out the addresses for the care
package
and send i don't care packages just be
quick
just be creative it could be empty it
could be filled with something fun
and cheeky and clever but i would never
tell people to do that but i'm sure it's
very
easy to find the address and send an i
don't care package them it's oddly very
specific
dr pepper why dr pepper it's ironic
given the fact that they didn't listen
to their doctors to begin with oh
very good red cove and then you got the
hard candy
and hair sprayed it sounds like a
scavenger hunt for a carnival sex worker
absolutely not that i would know
somebody or who's some
no i'm not gonna even say this out loud
because it'll get you gonna be doing
this for another two weeks
but i do um i do have some ideas for
what could
possibly go in the care package i can't
share it though
okay you don't set it on fire right
absolutely
not today 26 minutes before the top of
the hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now